SPARKY RHODE: Good afternoon,
everybody.
Welcome once again.
It's Wednesday afternoon, and we
are the EMEA-based Android
Developer Relations Team at
Google TV-- team here to talk
to you about Android
Development.
I'm Sparky, coming to you
from Munich, Germany.
And we've got Matt and Nick
and Rich in London, UK.
And who is this fourth
face that we see?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Hi, there.
We have a guest with us in the
UK office again this week.
This week it's Chris Banes.
CHRIS BANES: Hi, guys.
MATT GAUNT: [LAUGHS].
[LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: Just hi.
CHRIS BANES: Hi.
RICH HYNDMAN: Do you want to say
a little bit about Android
stuff that you've done
before, maybe?
Or--
CHRIS BANES: Besides stream
on over from--
RICH HYNDMAN: Spot total.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
So some of the stuff-- sort
of got pulled the refresh
library, wrote FriendCaster,
also it's a bit--
a lot, really--
that didn't quite
go with these.
RICH HYNDMAN: Generally
awesome in the Android
community over here.
So, hi.
CHRIS BANES: Hi.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS BANES: Hi to Richard.
SPARKY RHODE: Welcome
to the Hangout.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah,
good Hangout.
So we're hoping quite a lot
of you join in today--
[LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: Because we only
have three questions in the
Moderator for this week.
If not, it'll be quite
a short session.
So if you have Android
development questions, please
come along and join us
in the Hangout, or
comment on the G+ thread.
If you can't get in, then we'll
invite you in so you can
ask your questions live.
Else, add some more
questions into the
Moderator to keep us going.
SPARKY RHODE: Three questions.
I'm impressed.
That's a 50% improvement over
the last time I looked.
RICH HYNDMAN: [LAUGHS].
Two questions, and one thing
that says, "This is not a
question, but enjoy
your Hangout.
Thanks,
Andrew Kelly." [LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: One-man Moderator
machine when he's
not adding questions into
the Moderator, still
filling it up for us.
NICK BUTCHER: Andrew Kelly, on
G+ the other day, was saying,
when will Droidcon come
to Australia?
And I was telling him
that Droidcon's not
organized by Google.
It's a community-run event.
Anyone could set up
a Droidcon, so--
I think.
[LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, certainly.
Right.
NICK BUTCHER: So, I think
Andrew should
organize one in Australia.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: I will go.
RICH HYNDMAN: We can introduce
you to the Droidcon organizers
if you want to get--
au.droidcon.com.
NICK BUTCHER: I'm prepared
to go to Australia.
RICH HYNDMAN: I believe they do
have to license the name.
MATT GAUNT: No.
NICK BUTCHER: They
licensed the word
"Droid," yeah, they did.
MATT GAUNT: See, I thought
Droidcon wasn't organized by a
central thing.
It was basically like ad-hoc
people could do it.
And then, now they're discussing
that maybe they
should make it a slightly more
sort of collaborative effort
so that you have to kind of go
through them to then sell any
Droid components.
RICH HYNDMAN: If any of the
Droidcon organizers are
watching this--
MATT GAUNT: They are
free, though.
RICH HYNDMAN: They
are free, yeah.
If anyone knows, pop
in and tell us,
actually, so we stop guessing.
[LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: Because that's
just dangerous.
[LAUGHS].
Yossi.
Hey there.
Good to see you again.
Thanks for joining.
Do you have any questions
for us today?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Hi.
Hope you can hear me now.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, we
can hear you fine.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK.
Just wanted to ask about
implementing or using Google
Hangouts API inside an Android
application, and what are the
baseline guidelines for
that and so on?
RICH HYNDMAN: The Hangouts
[INAUDIBLE]?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, so
there aren't any.
Because there isn't any.
MATT GAUNT: [LAUGHS].
RICH HYNDMAN: To my knowledge,
that doesn't exist.
Have you found something
we don't know about?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No, we're
thinking to build an
application and try to see if
there is any API for Hangouts.
Also for Android, not
only for web.
RICH HYNDMAN: Uh-huh.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Didn't
find any.
So I just wanted to ask if--
RICH HYNDMAN: No, I mean the
people-- you should head to
the "Google+ Office Hours."
They host office hours as
well, at
developers.google.com/live,
and have a chat with them.
They might be able to talk to
you about any APIs that there
are for Hangouts.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: At the moment,
I think the Hangouts APIs
revolve around adding
functionality
to Hangouts, not--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: Sites.
[INAUDIBLE].
MALE SPEAKER: Their
applications.
RICH HYNDMAN: Who's
that making noise?
That's almost muted.
MATT GAUNT: [LAUGHS].
RICH HYNDMAN: I was gonna
say, where's Al Sutton
when you need him?
But of course, Al Sutton's
off playing with Booyah!
He got his first Booyah!
hardware during the week.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: So
he's probably--
CHRIS BANES: Swell.
RICH HYNDMAN: --just
playing games.
NICK BUTCHER: Just a ball.
RICH HYNDMAN: If you're
watching, Al, enjoy that.
Right.
I'm just going to pull up the
comments thread as well, just
to make sure we don't
miss anything.
NICK BUTCHER: One request
that I've seen.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
Are you there?
SPARKY RHODE: I notice that
we've been joined in the
Hangout by a couple
of newcomers.
We've got Paul, and we've
got Stephano.
Welcome, guys.
Do you have anything on
your mind that you'd
like to bring up?
Any Android-related topics
that you'd like
to talk about now?
PAUL: Hello?
Can you hear me OK?
MATT GAUNT: Hey, Paul.
PAUL: Hi.
Good to meet you guys
a week ago.
MATT GAUNT: You too.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, you too.
Hey.
PAUL: That was good fun, and
good to see what's going on
with Android.
MALE SPEAKER: Mm-hmm.
PAUL: I do have one
quick question.
I can't remember--
I spoke to somebody, I can't
remember who it was--
about submitting the
NFC fix as a patch.
MALE SPEAKER: Yep.
PAUL: Can someone tell
me where to go
or what to do, please?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
If you go to
source.android.com--
PAUL: Yep.
NICK BUTCHER: There's a section
there about how to
submit a change.
PAUL: Oh, OK.
Cool.
Sounds easy, then.
[LAUGHTER]
NICK BUTCHER: Well, yeah.
I guess so.
You have to kind of create your
own [? garret ?] and all
that stuff.
Yeah.
PAUL: OK.
Well, I'll have a look at
it anyway later on.
Thank you very much.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
You're welcome.
Any other questions?
Who asked about-- who's
just joined us?
MATT GAUNT: Stephano?
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
Stephano.
Welcome to the Hangout.
What's on your mind?
STEPHANO: Hello.
I am an Italian student.
I don't speak great English.
[LAUGHS].
SPARKY RHODE: That's fine.
STEPHANO: For money.
I develop only an
app for Android.
It's just a benchmark.
SPARKY RHODE: OK.
What sort of a benchmark?
Like performance?
STEPHANO: Yeah.
SPARKY RHODE: Are you doing
native code or like web
performance or Java VM?
What are you--
STEPHANO: No, job performance.
SPARKY RHODE: [INAUDIBLE].
OK.
Cool.
So how long have you
been working on it?
STEPHANO: About half a years.
SPARKY RHODE: OK.
So what's your impression
of Android as
a development platform?
Do you have any favorite APIs,
or something that you wish
that we would fix?
STEPHANO: Um--
sorry.
I didn't understand.
SPARKY RHODE: Oh.
So what parts about Android
do you like working with?
And what parts about Android do
you think maybe you would
like to see some changes in?
STEPHANO: For me, Android is
perfect at the moment.
NICK BUTCHER: [LAUGHS].
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah!
RICH HYNDMAN: I agree.
STEPHANO: It's a very
good platform.
SPARKY RHODE: OK.
Very well said.
I'll send you your money later.
[LAUGHTER]
SPARKY RHODE: [LAUGHS].
Cool.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
Just updating a couple of the
threads to make sure everybody
knows where the Moderator
and where this
session's actually at today.
NICK BUTCHER: Should we take a
look at some of the Moderator
questions, Sparky?
SPARKY RHODE: Sure.
There's not a whole lot
here, as I had said.
The first one's kind
of interesting.
This one's from our friend
Johan in the Netherlands.
Says he wants to create two
skins for the app, which he
equates to having different
resources.
And he wants to basically know,
what are best practices
for doing this?
Should he create a library
project with, then, two
different sets of resources,
or sort of riff on that?
And just as an aside, he also
mentions that he's using Maven
to build it, in case that
makes a difference.
Responses from Andrew
Kelly and Yossi
suggest using themes.
But I'm thinking maybe--
I mean, what if he doesn't
want the assets for both
branches of the app in
the same binary?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
SPARKY RHODE: In the same APK.
Like maybe one is for a client
or something like that.
NICK BUTCHER: Chris, FriendCast
is supporting
multiple themes.
How did you go about that?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
So all the graphics were
in the same APK.
So it was all done on
Styles and Themes.
Custom attributes.
NICK BUTCHER: And then
how do you set it?
You just call setTheme?
Or do you do it--
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, so in your
activity, before you call
super.onCreate, it's
copy before,
but you call setStyle--
is it setStyle or setTheme?
NICK BUTCHER: SetTheme.
RICH HYNDMAN: SetTheme, yeah.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: SetTheme.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
So you call that with your--
the style you want.
So you can call it-- so change
your other preference or
whatever you need to do.
NICK BUTCHER: So, if you change
style, you have to
recreate the activity?
CHRIS BANES: No.
It does it.
So as long as you call setStyle
before you call
super.onCreate, it works.
If you call it after,
bad things happen.
[LAUGHTER]
SPARKY RHODE: OK, so--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SPARKY RHODE: Dynamically--
you're dynamically switching
your theme--
basically, the drawable
resources that compose your
theme right at an
instantiation of
the activity, then?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
SPARKY RHODE: Wow.
OK.
MATT GAUNT: So you'd have to--
SPARKY RHODE: So this is--
CHRIS BANES: That's how I did.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: So you'd have to
do that for each activity?
You couldn't do that on like
an application one table?
CHRIS BANES: Yes, but if you
create a base activity--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
CHRIS BANES: And then
just extend from
it all, it all works.
RICH HYNDMAN: Good tip.
So this is going to depend on
whether he wants to have an
app which can change themes
on user request--
which you would restart your
activity and change it, and
put both sets of themes in the
APK-- or whether-- yeah.
You're trying to re-skin the
same application with multiple
clients, when you don't want all
the resources in both, in
which case the library project
would be a great way to go.
NICK BUTCHER: Mm.
RICH HYNDMAN: And then
add the themes to--
SPARKY RHODE: Have any of you
guys worked with apps that
have downloadable skins, like
Beautiful Widgets or
something like that?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
What about them?
SPARKY RHODE: I just
would like--
do you know how they organize
their themes there?
Are they--
NICK BUTCHER: It's
like a player.
[INAUDIBLE] then.
CHRIS BANES: Beautiful Widgets,
they download into
the SD card.
And then they load the images
via FRED, and then just set
the drawables on each view
to sort them manually.
SPARKY RHODE: Right.
So they're not using the
resource framework?
They're just using drawables?
CHRIS BANES: There are apps--
so all the apps where the
themes are done out
of a Google Play,
they're done by resources.
So I think you can access
external resources via
PackageManager, if I
remember rightly?
RICH HYNDMAN: Mm-hmm.
CHRIS BANES: But I've
not done it.
So, can't comment.
RICH HYNDMAN: Excellent.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
I know I've seen apps on other
platforms where it was-- you
could have these skins, and it
was very important that your
resources be numbered with
exactly the same identifiers
as in the base project,
and so--
RICH HYNDMAN: It's one example
of where developers and
designers collide.
For the latest updates, the
ultimates, [INAUDIBLE]
[? Marie ?]
wanted to change the
theme as he went
through to the countdown.
But of course, that
would require--
it was in a ViewPager, so he
could swipe across the
countdown, but it required
restarting the activity to
change the theme, which I didn't
find a solution around,
unfortunately.
So we couldn't get--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: And watch
them fake it out.
RICH HYNDMAN: Action bar.
Yeah.
[LAUGHS].
But the Action bar had tabs in
it, and a drop-down overflow,
and buttons.
And I didn't really
want to go there.
So it didn't happen.
MATT GAUNT: The only kind of
thing that I've done remotely
like this is the scenario
where you have multiple
clients wanting pretty
much the same app
with different themes.
And yeah.
The library route is probably
best way to go, because you
have to remember when you
publish into Play Store, you
need a different package name
from everyone else.
So then, yeah.
So you'd basically have to start
doing that about your
resources, so--
Yeah.
That's the only sort
of comment I have.
RICH HYNDMAN: [LAUGHS].
Nice.
OK.
Hopefully that's answered
your question, Johan.
I know you're gonna watch
this a bit later on.
Sorry, you've got some
comment on that?
Paul?
Were you just gonna--
jump in there?
PAUL: Yeah, I was just gonna
say something on a sort of
different topic.
But if you're talking
on this topic, I
can wait for a moment.
NICK BUTCHER: No, go for it.
I think we're done.
RICH HYNDMAN: Go on, then.
PAUL: On the 4.2, I'm quite
anxious in this ability to log
on to this tablet or device
for multiple users.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK?
PAUL: Can anyone shine a
bit more light on that?
For example, I presume the apps
have their own data areas
for-- per user.
Will things like Contacts
and other things be
user-specific as well?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes.
The answer is yes.
You--
it's very much like having your
own individual tablet.
PAUL: So like, everything would
be working in the same
way as the Contacts and--?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
The only thing that's shared are
the application binaries
themselves.
So--
PAUL: So if you download an app
under one user, the other
user would be able to
see that same app
downloaded into their--
no.
RICH HYNDMAN: No, but if they go
to Google Play and then try
and install that same app, it
will install instantly.
It won't do the download
again.
PAUL: OK.
So it just copies
itself in the--
locally.
RICH HYNDMAN: Locally, I don't
actually know if it's copying
itself or just setting
permissions or making it--
linking it or doing something.
But it becomes--
PAUL: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: It'll
be available.
The app binaries.
Yeah.
SPARKY RHODE: Hey, Rich, do you
know, what about apps that
download substantial amounts
of supplemental data?
Say, like your game apps that
have 400 megs of resources?
RICH HYNDMAN: That's gonna
depend on the app itself and
how they've implemented that.
So if they--
yeah.
I haven't tried it.
NICK BUTCHER: Hm.
RICH HYNDMAN: Not quite sure.
My guess is that it would have
to probably download that set
of resources again, but
I don't actually know.
We'll try and dig out some
recommendations for you.
PAUL: OK.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: On the fly.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: About
that issue?
RICH HYNDMAN: Sorry?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Regarding
the storage.
RICH HYNDMAN: Mm-hmm?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: If we were using
an external storage as
caching for images or so on.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Each user won't
see the folder we created for
the different users?
SPARKY RHODE: I believe
that's correct.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Because basically
today we're creating
a folder on the SD card, get
external storage, and then
we're creating a folder
for lazy loading the
images and so on.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
So an example is the Gallery
and the Cameras.
So if I go into one profile and
take a picture, it goes
into a slash SD card, DCIM,
whatever it is.
Puts it in there.
If I switch users, then I get a
completely different view of
that folder, and I can take--
I don't see the photos that
the original user took.
SPARKY RHODE: Hmm.
NICK BUTCHER: So each user
has a view of the
SD card, as it were.
SPARKY RHODE: Is it mounting a
completely separate volume?
RICH HYNDMAN: Well, this is--
all of our devices don't have
the external SD card,
of course.
So that could be a different
matter of people releasing
this with that.
I don't know how it would
work at the moment.
PAUL: Does anyone know
what security
implications this may have?
Although they're in different
areas, is it completely secure
in terms of-- from one
user to another?
SPARKY RHODE: I think it's a--
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
Pass to Nigel at the moment,
because we haven't tested it
out on any devices that
do have SD cards.
My guess is if you've actually
got an external SD card and
you're using this, then you can
still take it out and read
the space on it--
that you'd be able to see each
other's data on the SD card.
But I don't actually know.
There are no devices that
support that at the moment.
PAUL: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: For us
to try it out on.
NICK BUTCHER: And what do you
mean by completely secure?
I mean, what is that?
PAUL: What I mean is, from--
I don't mean by external
SD cards.
I mean from one user to
another, in terms of--
obviously, if they can't see the
data, they probably can't
read it in any other way
outside of the app.
SPARKY RHODE: I believe the
intention is for the users to
be completely firewalled
from each other.
PAUL: OK.
SPARKY RHODE: Our sample use
case is an enterprise use
case, right?
Where you've got two enterprise
users sharing one
physical tablet and--
PAUL: Exactly.
NICK BUTCHER: I call that sample
use case is the family.
[LAUGHS].
You have a tablet--
RICH HYNDMAN: I agree, yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Coffee table.
You don't want to hand it to
your kids when it's logged
into your Gmail and your
Twitter and everything.
CHRIS BANES: But I'm sure if you
turn on the encryption--
it's gonna be turn on encrypt
storage or what
the option's called--
that at least encrypts
the SD image.
I'm guessing.
I don't know.
MATT GAUNT: It would
be interesting.
If you were encrypting stuff on
the SD card, you'd have to
use a different key for each--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: User.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: And then at that
point, it would be
specific to that user.
That might be quite a nice
way of doing it.
SPARKY RHODE: I seem to recall
that the coffee table model
was explicitly not one of the
use cases that we tried to
optimize for this generation
of the feature.
Because that implies things like
an administrative user,
aka a parent, who is controlling
the tablet usage
experience of another
user, aka the child.
And that sort of management
infrastructure is not included.
NICK BUTCHER: Huh.
RICH HYNDMAN: [SIGH].
Interesting.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Hm.
RICH HYNDMAN: [LAUGHS].
Yeah.
That's certainly my use
case for it, anyway.
MATT GAUNT: Hm.
RICH HYNDMAN: To keep my own
profile secure, and while the
kids still get to play
their games.
And it's very easy just to
switch between the profiles.
Just tap on the Power button.
And hand it over.
MATT GAUNT: Yes.
You've had a recent use case
of that haven't you?
[LAUGHS].
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes.
I have.
MATT GAUNT: So we've been joined
by some new people.
RICH HYNDMAN: Let's have a look
who's in here with us.
SPARKY RHODE: I have to say, I
was stunned the other day to
walk into the living room
and discover that the
three-year-old had found my
Galaxy Tab, taken it down,
unlocked it, started a game, and
actually been playing the
game all without any adult
assistance whatsoever.
Nobody told her how
to play this game.
She just started doing it.
PAUL: There you go.
RICH HYNDMAN: Their
skills these days.
MATT GAUNT: [LAUGHS].
RICH HYNDMAN: Welcome to the new
guys who have just joined
us in the Hangout--
Leslie, I think it's
Christian--
LESLIE: Hi.
RICH HYNDMAN: Nice
to see you guys.
Do any of you have any
questions for us?
LESLIE: Yeah.
Do you guys know how to take
a snapshot in code?
I found this screen shot code.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LESLIE: I actually want to do it
and send the image across a
connection.
MATT GAUNT: So, do you mean take
a screen shot from code,
is that basically it?
LESLIE: Yes.
MATT GAUNT: Of the whole
device, or just do
it within your app?
LESLIE: The whole device,
the whole screen.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh, no.
That's not possible.
That would be a security hazard
if you had a service
running in the background
that could take screen
shots of the device.
You can take screen shots
of your application.
LESLIE: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Anything
else isn't available
to the average product.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah, right.
RICH HYNDMAN: It's all
in a secure product.
MALE SPEAKER: [LAUGHS].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LESLIE: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: There's nothing.
CHRIS BANES: DDMS isn't?
[INAUDIBLE].
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LESLIE: Yeah.
I found the DDMS solution,
but it's quite untidy.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes.
LESLIE: And we want to put this
on thousands of devices,
so we kept [INAUDIBLE]
want to do that.
Mm-hmm.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: Is this purely
for testing?
LESLIE: It's more for
road support.
MALE SPEAKER: Shall I go?
LESLIE: It's a matter of showing
us what the user has
on the other side.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
It's a dog show.
Yeah, I think it will be fine.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
You'd either have to guide them
through taking the screen
shots or [INAUDIBLE].
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
MALE SPEAKER: He said
he will not go.
LESLIE: OK.
Well, I tossed.
RICH HYNDMAN: Don't you have
access to [INAUDIBLE]?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LESLIE: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Front rows?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
LESLIE: Ah, no.
We're putting it on Samsung
devices now, so we can't get
the app signed.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
Fair enough.
No, in which case I don't
know of a way.
Samsung do have a Screen Shot
button of their own, so maybe
if you're talking to them, you
can ask them about that.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah,
that's actually--
RICH HYNDMAN: And if they have
any APIs for it for apps that
they're assigned, you shouldn't
have problems.
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
MALE SPEAKER: No, your
mute button.
[INAUDIBLE].
LESLIE: Yeah.
The signature's not a
problem with you.
We can get that done.
MALE SPEAKER: Traditional
what?
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
LESLIE: They used, I think,
called [? Sortie, ?]
and it's all built
into their API.
And we don't especially want
to use [? Sortie, ?] but it
costs a fortune.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
He's heard of that.
MALE SPEAKER: Remember
what our teachers--
RICH HYNDMAN: But
we're back now.
OK?
Cheers, Leslie for
that question.
LESLIE: Yep.
RICH HYNDMAN: Do you
have any others?
LESLIE: Not right now.
RICH HYNDMAN: All right, anybody
else who has joined us
have any questions?
NICK BUTCHER: Just [INAUDIBLE]
Hangout.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh, really?
Yeah, we've got--
I hear people coming in.
Have they?
NICK BUTCHER: Loads
of questions.
RICH HYNDMAN: All right.
FEMALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
mute?
RICH HYNDMAN: Can we just get
a mute from, maybe, Leslie?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, there we go.
RICH HYNDMAN: Excellent,
thank you.
MATT GAUNT: Cool.
RICH HYNDMAN: So--
MATT GAUNT: I think we've
got a question?
RICH HYNDMAN: A question
from--?
MATT GAUNT: There we go.
RICH HYNDMAN: What are
you pointing at?
MALE SPEAKER: You're with--
MATT GAUNT: The girl
with her hand up.
I can't see--
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh, Donna.
Hey.
MATT GAUNT: Sorry.
RICH HYNDMAN: You
can just speak.
It's OK.
MAXIM: [LAUGHS].
RICH HYNDMAN: Nice
to see you there.
MAXIM: Nice to see you too.
RICH HYNDMAN: Is this the first
time you've joined one
of our Hangouts?
MALE SPEAKER: Oh.
MAXIM: Yes, well, actually I
have been watching on quite or
for long time over YouTube,
but I didn't participate.
So [INAUDIBLE].
MATT GAUNT: Long time watcher,
first time joiner.
RICH HYNDMAN: I can't actually
see your name on the screen.
What was your name?
MAXIM: My name is Maxim.
RICH HYNDMAN: Hey, Maxim.
SPARKY RHODE: Maxim, hello.
RICH HYNDMAN: Thanks
for joining.
And what's your question?
MAXIM: So I had an application
on the Market which uses phone
states and then-- well,
obviously I have--
it won't set permission.
And I'm importing the
new updates--
just yesterday.
Tried to upload the new update
and somehow Market tells me
that it's now targeting less
devices than it's used to.
And apparently it's because
it has edits and
new permissions there.
Well, it's not [INAUDIBLE]
manifest, but the Market
shows that I have--
it's called low permission.
And it's saying it's got
a severe situation.
In fact, I don't want to--
NICK BUTCHER: So you're sure--
you're definitely asking for
any new permissions
in the new APK?
MAXIM: I'm not asking
for a permission
which has been added.
It seems that it has
been added somehow.
NICK BUTCHER: So the source
of truth there is to do--
use aapt.
So if you do aapt
dump badging--
MAXIM: Mm-hmm.
NICK BUTCHER: And then, in
the path to your APK,
that will tell you--
that will export all
the permissions.
Because that will show you even
the implied permissions,
like some permissions are
implied by others.
So it will explicitly list out
all the permissions you are
asking for.
So that's the source of truth.
So if you can do that, and if
it doesn't match up to what
you're seeing when you upload
it to the Play Store, then
that sounds like a bug.
So let us know if that
doesn't match up.
MAXIM: I see.
I see.
OK, I will try it using that.
So actually the secret--
if I understand correctly, the
situation is that some of the
libraries that I may be using
may be requesting for that
permission.
Is that correct?
NICK BUTCHER: It could
well be, yeah.
Well, that would have to be
in your manifest, right?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: They can't
just imply them.
MAXIM: Oh no.
It was not under the
installation to me, because I
don't see it anywhere,
and it's there.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
MAXIM: Oh.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, yeah.
Check your manifest and use
aapt dump badging--
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Is the way to
get to the bottom of this.
MAXIM: All right.
Thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
No, thanks for the
question again.
Let us know how you get on.
Oh, we seem to be joined by
some new people as well.
Welcome to the Hangout.
Does anyone have any Android
development questions?
[INDISTINCT VOICES]
NICK BUTCHER: [LAUGHS].
MATT GAUNT: Ah--
RICH HYNDMAN: What?
CHRISTIAN: Be there.
Be there.
SPARKY RHODE: Let's
pick on somebody.
How about Christian?
Christian, what's up?
[LAUGHS].
SPARKY RHODE: If you're not
able to talk where you are
now, you're also welcome to
type into the sidebar.
RICH HYNDMAN: Just
click on Chat.
[INDISTINCT FEMALE VOICE]
SPARKY RHODE: I'll just go and
see if there's any new
questions in the Moderator.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
SPARKY RHODE: There is.
There is.
NICK BUTCHER: Marvelous.
CHRISTIAN: Or a couple
words of it.
SPARKY RHODE: Or--
RICH HYNDMAN: Whatever.
Bring up the trusty Nexus 7.
[INDISTINCT FEMALE VOICE]
SPARKY RHODE: "After uploading
new app version to Market, two
new permissions were
automatically added."
RICH HYNDMAN: We just answered
that question.
MATT GAUNT: [LAUGHS].
SPARKY RHODE: Oh,
that's right.
This is actually Maxim's
question.
OK, so this is Maxim.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE] about
the Action bar, maybe.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SPARKY RHODE: "[INAUDIBLE]
want to implement Action bar.
But in Developer Console, half
of the users show they're
still using 2.3."
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE].
SPARKY RHODE: "So shall I create
two different APKs?"
No, use ActionBarSherlock.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yep.
ActionBarSherlock's a great
solution for that, and it's
exactly what it's meant for.
It's very easy to add in, and
works with the support library
Fragments and everything.
MALE SPEAKER: Hm.
[INDISTINCT FEMALE VOICE]
RICH HYNDMAN: Next one?
NICK BUTCHER: Waits for it.
MATT GAUNT: [LAUGHS].
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, so--
MATT GAUNT: I'm waiting.
NICK BUTCHER: Lucas--
I guess it's Lucas Rutger-- asks
a question about themes,
and that certain OEMs have
changed the default themes
that apps ship with.
So he says that, "assuming that
the Options menu is black
in Gingerbread is not
necessarily true on all devices.
How should you handle this?"
So, yeah, this is problematic.
And I guess this is why we
introduced Holo styles which
OEMs can't modify, so that you
can extend those styles and
know what you're gonna get.
The best advice is
really to use the
built-in Styles and Themes.
So you can use the
things like--
the text styles like inverse
and color primary--
color inverse--
I think that's who it is?
CHRIS BANES: That's correct.
NICK BUTCHER: Styles
that you can use.
So, using those styles,
hopefully if they've modified
one of the values, they should
have modified the other value,
is really the best you can do
in those circumstances.
And your advice--
SPARKY RHODE: [INAUDIBLE].
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Maybe
using the folder--
the library Holo everywhere?
MATT GAUNT: Mm-hmm.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, not
a bad solution.
Put Holo everywhere.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Put Holo on--
NICK BUTCHER: On the Options
menu, but yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
CHRIS BANES: The Option menu
isn't customizable.
Their themes.
Yes, they need more
[? platform stuff. ?]
You'll not be able to change
anything further.
There are hacks you can
do, but they're hacks.
[LAUGHTER]
YOSSI ELKRIEF: [LAUGHS],
NICK BUTCHER: I guess he's
probably asking about icon
colors and stuff like that.
So you might want to set--
RICH HYNDMAN: Or use the
system icons, maybe.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: There's always been
a set of guidelines for
system icons and stuff, like
to replicate them.
So--
RICH HYNDMAN: Really?
MATT GAUNT: Always do try and
stay with that if you're
looking at icon--
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, the icon
builder only does one set,
doesn't it?
For Gingerbread.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
If you start playing around with
colored icons and stuff,
and we're not really
recommending it, then we're
not recommending it
for a reason.
So yeah, you're gonna
have a bad time.
[LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: Taking a
slight [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: Where's-- oh,
Sparky's still there.
I thought we'd lost him
for a second there.
Next one?
Shoot.
SPARKY RHODE: Mm.
RICH HYNDMAN: What's that?
SPARKY RHODE: Ah.
"Is there a right way to add
tabs to a multi-pane view?" He
goes on to say he was talking
about doing two panes, where
the right pane needs to have
tabs in it, like the one in
the Google Play Store, with a
menu on the left-hand side.
Hm.
RICH HYNDMAN: That's right.
Go to the Play Store "Hours."
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
[LAUGHS].
RICH HYNDMAN: So, Chris?
You want to--
CHRIS BANES: I actually
went for this pane
every day when I was--
I've done enough of mine.
I decided not to go with
tabs, and I went
with dialogs instead.
So we set it on the
right pane.
I'd just open a dialog.
The other way to do it is
via a library called
ViewPageIndicator.
So I'm guessing that the right
pane is in a ViewPager.
So you can use the Indicator
to actually
show where you are.
It's not quite Tab, but
it's near enough that
you could use it.
So you replicate the Tab
function in the right pane.
And that's the way I'd
probably go with it.
RICH HYNDMAN: Sounds good.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah, I think
that's a good answer.
If I was doing it myself, I
would probably cop out and
just use a ListView.
[LAUGHS].
But that's just me.
RICH HYNDMAN: I'd put the
tabs in the Action bar,
but there you go.
CHRIS BANES: [? Tourilla ?]
is the tourist's top left.
And then the right pane is--
RICH HYNDMAN: But yeah,
I'm not [INAUDIBLE].
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
it's not that way.
RICH HYNDMAN: Ringo?
[LAUGHS].
It's still what I think.
[LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: What would
you do, Nick?
NICK BUTCHER: So, well, it
says you've got like a
two-pane view, and the
right-hand pane is--
RICH HYNDMAN: That's
not-- yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Swipeable?
CHRIS BANES: Well, not so much
swipeable, but changeable.
See?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
CHRIS BANES: It's got temper.
NICK BUTCHER: [INAUDIBLE]
in the pane.
So yeah, ViewPageIndicator.
So you can't use Pager
as a title strip?
You tried using that?
CHRIS BANES: You can use Pager
Title Strip, yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
What source from?
[LAUGHTER]
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
I'm getting very confused
as well.
Because that's what I think--
CHRIS BANES: Well, that was
my-- well, I did say Page
Title Strip, but--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, Page Title
Strip or ViewPageIndicator
will do the same thing, then.
Will get you there.
SPARKY RHODE: I'm trying to
bring up the Store to see if I
can figure out what he's talking
about, but I'm not
really seeing this--
RICH HYNDMAN: No, I think
we've figured it out.
It's all right.
I think we can--
go on, say it, Matt.
Say it.
MATT GAUNT: Next, my friend.
CHRIS BANES: Oh, yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: [LAUGHS].
Next message.
NICK BUTCHER: So Droid Nerd in
Germany asks, "Is there a
possibility to find out the home
country of a logged-in
Google account on Android?
We want to show content based
on the user's home country.
The home country would be
used for display correct
currencies, too."
MATT GAUNT: Hm.
NICK BUTCHER: I don't
think there is a
way to find the country.
I think your best bet is
probably to create a locale of
the device.
SPARKY RHODE: Right.
And that's a user setting, not
necessarily a physical presence.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, but you
can check the IP address.
RICH HYNDMAN: You could
do a Google--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Know it's
your IP or something.
RICH HYNDMAN: Who knows
where that runs?
NICK BUTCHER: No, well,
actually where the
device is, not the--
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
The Google Play Store knows
where you are, but that's all
server-side detection.
That's not your device.
RICH HYNDMAN: You could check
the SIM country as well.
NICK BUTCHER: So my advice
would be not
to do any of this.
It would be to respect the
locale of the user's cell--
the device.
Because the user has control
over these things.
Like currencies, how
they're displayed,
dates, how they're displayed.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh--
NICK BUTCHER: If you try and get
a bit too clever, then it
can be annoying.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, but they're
probably trying to
implement our recommendation of
putting the cost of their
inner items into their
application.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah--
RICH HYNDMAN: Maybe
it's just--
SPARKY RHODE: The Location
Manager's your best bet.
RICH HYNDMAN: That would be--
NICK BUTCHER: Just respect
his locale, then.
RICH HYNDMAN: Like--
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah, yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Google respect--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Basically, the
locale is the best option.
MATT GAUNT: I was over
in Mountain View--
RICH HYNDMAN: No, no.
The locale is you-- if you've
got yours set to UK--
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SPARKY RHODE: I think the best
bet for home country is just
to create a locale.
RICH HYNDMAN: So how
did you find out?
MATT GAUNT: Where--
RICH HYNDMAN: Where the Play
Store's gonna return.
MATT GAUNT: Oh.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Or maybe
that's not the case
they're asking about.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
My suggestion would be to
stick with the locale.
And then, if that's not their
actual home place, as in,
let's say they are
from Germany, but
they switch to English--
British for some reason--
that's what they're more
comfortable with--
then give them the option
to change it
within Settings somewhere.
RICH HYNDMAN: Mm-hmm.
MATT GAUNT: So it will
essentially override it.
Just use it as a default,
essentially.
NICK BUTCHER: (WHISPERING)
Just make it a Setting?
CHRIS BANES: Yeah, that
they need to choose.
MATT GAUNT: Just try and be
clever once, and then after
that, let the user change it.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: [LAUGHS].
RICH HYNDMAN: Try and
be clever, and
when you get it wrong--
[LAUGHTER]
MATT GAUNT: Let the
user take over.
RICH HYNDMAN: Let them
override it.
Yeah.
That could work.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah, but
basically the Play Store holds
and checks the locale and
also checks the IP.
No?
From where the device
is checking the--
MATT GAUNT: The Play Store
does all sorts of stuff.
RICH HYNDMAN: The Play Store
does get quite a
few different checks.
CHRIS BANES: Right.
SPARKY RHODE: I mean, there's
a couple of models.
Like, if you're offering--
like they said--
recommendations, restaurants,
shopping, something like that,
then use the Location Manager.
If you're offering content
that's kind of spaceless,
like, say, you want to watch a
video and you want to know
what language to play
the soundtrack in,
then use the locale.
MATT GAUNT: See, the weird thing
that I've found since
talking to people in different
countries, is that, quite
often, they don't necessarily
want to consume content in
their native tongue.
They quite often don't want
the dubbed version.
Just a brief side point.
Anyway.
So, yeah.
[LAUGHS].
SPARKY RHODE: I've talked
about people about that.
Because Germany is a
country that's big
enough where Western--
the entertainment content is
almost always dubbed into the
local language.
And the consensus that I've
found among the people that
I've talked to here is that,
in fact, while there is a
small cadre of people who always
prefer it in original
version, overwhelmingly, most
consumers do want it dubbed
into their language.
NICK BUTCHER: Hmm.
SPARKY RHODE: Or at
least, that's the
case here in Germany.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I think
we probably deal
with a selection bias.
And people we're talking to
probably speak English.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah, true.
True.
NICK BUTCHER: Next question on
the Moderator asks "if there's
any general tips for finding
and resolving an annoying,
unknown source of battery
drain." So, I'm gonna guess
it's a developer question like
you've got a drain in your
app, not just generally my
device is running low on
battery, or anything
like that.
SPARKY RHODE: Right.
I would say, look at Trevor's
talk from Google I/O, where
he's giving the run-down
on the--
was it TraceView?
Is that what it's called?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, if you'd--
find out.
NICK BUTCHER: So my general
advice is a couple of vendor
tools out there from some of the
Silicon vendors that will
help you do this.
So I think ARM has a tool which
will help you track the
power usage and so on, depending
on which chips that
your device is running.
But generally my advice on
these issues is, you're
running on power if you're
powering something up.
So if you're keeping the screen
on, if you're holding a
wait clock, or if you're
doing network,
essentially, are the biggies.
So make sure you understand
your usage of those,
especially the wait clock.
Probably the wait clock--
CHRIS BANES: Location is on.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: There was a
presentation down at Droidcon
UK on Dr Power.
It's one of the apps in the
Play Store that can
help you with this.
And it does something similar
to the battery stats, but it
does break it down in
a lot more detail.
So I was just looking
at that now.
SPARKY RHODE: Right.
There's some good sort of best
practices, like don't use--
say, if you're doing networking,
don't do polling
if you don't have to.
If your data is coming at sort
of unpredictable times, then
have a server-side component
that can send you a Google
Cloud message
quasi-asynchronously.
Or, if you are going
to do polling,
don't use exact alarms.
Use something like inexact
repeating alarms that will
sort of converge your
wake-up times onto a
few selected intervals.
And then all of your apps,
who are all using inexact
repeating alarms together, can
all be woken up at the same
time, do the network, and
shut back down again.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
A lot of this boils down to
don't do any work you don't
have to do as well.
So things like listening to the
state of the battery and
the network and adjusting your
behavior accordingly.
So if the user's battery is
under 20%, then maybe you back
off the polling behavior, and
don't call so aggressively.
Or maybe you shut down
a certain receiver if
you don't need it.
It's just do as little
work as possible.
So one of the things I quite
often see is people will use
the boot completed listener to
schedule any alarms that they
might need to reset,
like, say, for
some polling behavior.
Put a [INAUDIBLE] the boot
receiver is checked wherever
something should happen.
And if not, just return.
Whereas you're much better off
actually just using the Patch
Manager to disable your boot
receiver if it's not going to
do anything when you boot,
rather than causing an extra
piece of work to be done at
quite a strenuous time when
the system's still starting
up and there's loads and
stuff's going on.
So it's just like part of being
a good citizen, really.
Just don't do any work
you don't have to do.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
Any more questions from
inside the Hangout?
MATT GAUNT: Jeff Gosling would
like to be added to the
Hangout, and he has
a question.
RICH HYNDMAN: Ooh.
OK.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10.
He's not gonna get
in, [LAUGHS]
but I will add him in anyway,
and hopefully--
NICK BUTCHER: We've got some new
live participants as well.
Any questions from people
in the Hangout?
RICH HYNDMAN: Hey--
NICK BUTCHER: Giuseppe.
RICH HYNDMAN: Giuseppe from--
NICK BUTCHER: I recognize
Giuseppe's art.
RICH HYNDMAN: [FINGER SNAP]
--Voice Pro last week.
NICK BUTCHER: Aye then.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yep.
NICK BUTCHER: Hey, Giuseppe,
any questions?
Or are you just hanging out?
Oh, we can't hear you,
I think you're muted.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
If you're in a position where
you can't or don't want to
talk, then feel free to
type your questions
into the Chat window.
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh, we do
have some questions.
CHRIS BANES: That's
not questions.
SPARKY RHODE: Oh.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE] asks,
is the home country--
CHRIS BANES: Sorry I took
my [INAUDIBLE].
SPARKY RHODE: Question
incoming from--
how do we say this name?
Marijn?
Is that your name?
RICH HYNDMAN: Marjin, maybe?
I don't know.
CHRIS BANES: Marian?
SPARKY RHODE: I-J-N.
That's Dutch.
Looks like Mahr-ein.
RICH HYNDMAN: Please,
I am trying to--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Mahr-een?
RICH HYNDMAN: --clarify
my problem.
It'll work.
We can guess his name later.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Mahrleen.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
SPARKY RHODE: [LAUGHS].
MATT GAUNT: So, no questions
from Google+.
[INDISTINCT MALE VOICE]
MATT GAUNT: No?
SPARKY RHODE: It is a slow
Wednesday afternoon.
[LAUGHTER]
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK, I'll ask
a question, if you want.
MALE SPEAKER: Go on, Yossi.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Basically, when
you do a search on the Play
Store for a specific developer,
you can see all the
apps [ECHO]
the developer [ECHO]
on Play Store.
Is it a good convention to
show a WebView on my app
showing all the apps I have
on the Play Store?
Maybe like a cover flow or
something like that?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
No, I don't see any
reason why not.
Quite often people will just
link out to their Publisher
page on Play Store.
But if you wanted to have more
control over the presentation,
then that's not a
bad thing to do.
I'd just say, do it courteously
to your users.
Like maybe put it under--
if you have an About screen,
perhaps you can have a "Get
More Apps From Us" or
something like that?
RICH HYNDMAN: Mm-hmm.
I personally just, yeah, from
the Settings menu, from the
Overflow menu I have in my Apps
button, take you straight
into the Play Store.
But if you want to put the
effort into designing a--
I guess it's one extra level.
SPARKY RHODE: There's one
publisher I'm thinking of who
seems to like to put up a splash
screen where they show
you several ads of other titles
of their apps, and
then, off to the side, a button
that says, "Click here
to play the game that you've
just launched."
MATT GAUNT: That sounds handy.
SPARKY RHODE: That kind of--
I don't know.
It bugs me a little bit.
Like, I at least want the title
that I selected to be
very prominently displayed.
And it would be nice if I didn't
have to have one extra
click to confirm the title that
I just selected amongst.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah,
that sounds overly
aggressive to me.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
Basically what I wanted was
to show a selector on the
Settings or something, and show
a My Apps option, and
then show all the related
apps to that developer.
SPARKY RHODE: Yeah.
I mean, if you want it as like
an About Us, and had a nice
marquee with all of your apps
on About Us, I think that
would be a great way to go.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: I think
someone like LevelUp
do this, don't they?
And Beautiful Widgets.
I think they do a quite
decent job of that.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Oh,
[INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: So, Marjin's
come back again, and he's
drawn us a picture of
the layout that he
was trying to build.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, this
is the tabs in--
RICH HYNDMAN: This was
the tabs layout
in multi-pane, yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: That
you just saw.
I'll just show the picture
to people inside.
So we've got a ListView
on the left-hand side.
On the right-hand side, there's
a Fragment with a
ListView inside it, and some
tabs across the top, which is,
I think, what we were
expecting to see.
NICK BUTCHER: Mm-hmm.
RICH HYNDMAN: And he has
commented to say--
would you mind, Chris?
I'm getting a bit old for this.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS BANES: "Made a quick
drawing of my question.
I had the question about
multi-pane view
and tabs that link.
I'm using Fragments.
I need tabs in with detail
Fragments, just like the Play
Store, but it doesn't show."
NICK BUTCHER: Oh.
So his question is, Fragments
within Fragments.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: All right.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Um--
CHRIS BANES: "Or I cannot edit
the title of the tabs or read
the IDs."
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
MATT GAUNT: Could you use
ViewPager with just views?
Don't you do something on
that in your blog posts?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes, certainly you
can have ViewPagers with
ListViews inside them without
having Fragments.
And then the second Fragment
would have tabs at the top,
which page between a--
NICK BUTCHER: Not just ListView,
but he adds views.
RICH HYNDMAN: I was gonna
say with ViewPager.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, so he
thinks you can use views
rather than Fragments.
RICH HYNDMAN: Mm-hmm.
MATT GAUNT: So would
that work?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, it would
work if it was simple enough.
CHRIS BANES: And why
do the tabs need
to be in the Fragment?
I would question that.
Why can't it be--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, that's
what I'm saying, yeah.
CHRIS BANES: Why can't it just
be in the activity map?
MATT GAUNT: Because
then it would
cover the entire surface.
So you'd have the
Fragment that--
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Yeah.
You want to see them only on
the right pane and not all
over the screen.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, but
you can do that
with includes anyway.
Like--
I don't think it's--
any reason it has to
be a Fragment.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
You could fight the tabs
by copying the last--
RICH HYNDMAN: So what
you're saying--
CHRIS BANES: ActionBarSherlock
call.
RICH HYNDMAN: So instead
of having--
NICK BUTCHER: So the left thing
would be a Fragment.
RICH HYNDMAN: Left the ListView
would be a Fragment--
sorry, the--
NICK BUTCHER: Left pane
would be a Fragment.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yep.
NICK BUTCHER: And it's just
a view holding the--
CHRIS BANES: The
linear layout.
Top would be your tabs--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
CHRIS BANES: And under that,
with a layout weight of one,
would be your Fragment.
RICH HYNDMAN: Fragment
on this side--
NICK BUTCHER: And a View Pager
which holds [INAUDIBLE].
RICH HYNDMAN: Linear layout
on this side.
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
Then tabs in the
linear layout--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: So--
CHRIS BANES: ViewPager all.
RICH HYNDMAN: ViewPager that.
MARIJN: So my mike is working
again, thankfully.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yay!
MARIJN: So what I meant was, is
that on the left side eye
of this menu which displays
a couple of data types.
RICH HYNDMAN: Mm-hmm.
MARIJN: And on the
right side you
have a couple of ListViews.
In this particular case,
I have three ListViews.
And because I need
to target both--
oh.
There you are.
[LAUGHS].
Because I need to target both
mobile phones and tablets--
NICK BUTCHER: Sure.
MARIJN: It wasn't natural enough
to put those ListViews
just on top of each other.
So I was looking for a tabbed
solution with a tab top--
Tab bar in the top.
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
MARIJN: But somehow
the TabHost isn't
showing in my app, so--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Don't use TabHost.
MARIJN: "Don't use TabHost."
And what's the alternative?
NICK BUTCHER: So that's been
deprecated now to use the
Action bar star tabs.
So, yeah.
Using Action bar or
ActionBarSherlock.
MARIJN: But isn't the Action
bar just used for--
NICK BUTCHER: So,
yeah, it has--
MARIJN: The apps?
NICK BUTCHER: --its own cache
system, but it won't-- it'll
do tabs in the Action bar on
tablets rather than in line.
So basically you can use
a thing called the
PagerStripTitle, which is in
the compatibility library.
See, because that would get
it within your key pager.
MARIJN: Could you tag that
in PageViewTitle?
Or--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
If you use Eclipse templates,
if you just generate a new
project, and generate one with
swipeable tabs, it'll generate
all the code you need.
And that's the best way
to kind of, like, look
at how to do it.
MARIJN: OK.
So the layout's covered for
the swipeable tabs?
I could just copy and paste, in
this case, to the friends?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, it will show
you how to do it, yeah.
You just [INAUDIBLE]
your own adapter.
MARIJN: Thanks very much.
NICK BUTCHER: Welcome.
OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: [SIGHS].
KRISTAN UCCELLO: All right.
I got a question for you guys.
NICK BUTCHER: Hey.
KRISTAN UCELLO: Hey.
MATT GAUNT: Hey.
KRISTAN UCELLO: How's
it going?
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, right.
I was gonna say.
[LAUGHTER]
KRISTAN UCELLO: Yeah, you guys
should recognize me, maybe.
At least Matt does.
SPARKY RHODE: Oh.
I'm loving the hat.
KRISTAN UCELLO: Ah.
Well, we got DevRel booth
stuff going on
in Charlie's today.
So--
but I do have an Android
question.
I'm building an app, and I'm
trying to use a service to
collect JSON data from a web
service, mung that data, stick
it into a database, and then
make that data available via a
content provider to my
main activities.
What I've noticed is, I'm able
to fetch the data without
issue, I'm able to parse
it, standard JSON,
dump it in the database.
The moment I try and access
the data from the content
provider later-- and I'm using
the content provider from the
service as well to
inject the data.
When I try and use the content
provider from the activity, I
get nothing back from
my cursors.
They're always empty.
SPARKY RHODE: Hmm.
That doesn't sound right.
NICK BUTCHER: Sounds like--
[LAUGHTER]
NICK BUTCHER: Sounds like a
problem with your projection.
KRISTAN UCELLO: I thought
that at first.
But these are very,
very simple.
Like, I'm basically doing
it on one key.
It's like, I have a YouTube ID,
and it's just like, give
me the first result that
matches this ID.
And I'll move the--
RICH HYNDMAN: Have you tried--
SPARKY RHODE: Maybe you're--
like, if you're not calling
swapCursor in your
onLoadComplete, or something
simple like that.
KRISTAN UCELLO: SwapCursor.
I don't know about that one.
Explain a little bit more?
SPARKY RHODE: Um--
NICK BUTCHER: Are you
using loaders?
KRISTAN UCELLO: Sorry?
NICK BUTCHER: Are you
using loaders?
KRISTAN UCELLO: I don't
think so [LAUGHS].
CHRIS BANES: No, that--
NICK BUTCHER: So you're just
doing a ContentResolver.query?
KRISTAN UCELLO: Yeah.
CHRIS BANES: Have you checked
that the data is actually
hitting the database?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, that would
be my next question.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah,
can the service--
KRISTAN UCELLO: Yeah.
The data is in the database.
What I did was, I pulled the
MySQL data right from the
device onto my system
and checked it out.
And it's all there.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: Can the service
read it back out of the
content provider again after
it's written it in?
KRISTAN UCELLO: No.
That's--
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
So it's--
KRISTAN UCELLO: That's
the weird part.
Once it goes in, it doesn't
want to come out.
But when I try and do inserts of
the same data again, I get
database exceptions
stating that the--
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, definitely
servers.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
RICH HYNDMAN: Probably dodgy
on the reading of
the data back out.
If the data's in there, and the
content provider's just
saying there isn't any.
Maybe just mail through
the [LAUGHS]
comment?
KRISTAN UCELLO: All right.
I'll send it to Matt today.
And you guys maybe
can take a look.
Because I've been stuck on it
for a day or two, and I've got
to get past this.
[LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: Right.
NICK BUTCHER: Sounds like
your projection to me.
Have you got--
KRISTAN UCELLO: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: --an ID column,
like an underscore ID column?
KRISTAN UCELLO: What did I do?
I don't think I did.
Maybe that is the problem.
Although I thought--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KRISTAN UCELLO: I thought there
was an implied one.
SPARKY RHODE: Hold on, base-- is
it implements BaseColumns?
Or is it extends BaseColumns?
Do you remember, Nick?
CHRIS BANES: Implements.
SPARKY RHODE: Implements
BaseColumns.
CHRIS BANES: I think the
variable is on there.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: I don't
remember.
I always use copy IE shared
and extend it.
[LAUGHTER]
KRISTAN UCELLO: The only problem
with that is the YT
Player has stopped working.
MATT GAUNT: Oh, yeah.
That's because the certificates
probably expired
for the API.
KRISTAN UCELLO: Yeah.
Yeah.
SPARKY RHODE: Oh, right.
Every year we have to regenerate
our developer
certificates, don't we?
KRISTAN UCELLO: This is the
YouTube player API.
It's set to expire every two
weeks after release, because
it's not launched yet, so--
RICH HYNDMAN: Oh god, yeah.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
At the moment, the API is
changing slightly, because
we're doing [INAUDIBLE]
getting feedback.
So the YouTube team are spending
a lot of time kind of
tweaking it, but
they're also--
it's kind of a fail-safe way,
and a really awful way of
being sure no one publishes
it to the Play Store.
Because then it--
KRISTAN UCELLO: [LAUGHS].
MATT GAUNT: --it's live,
and then they change
it, it starts breaking.
So--
KRISTAN UCELLO: Yeah.
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
I think it's just their way
of just making sure that
everything is kind
of gonna tick
along without any problems.
RICH HYNDMAN: It's been
a while now [LAUGHS].
MATT GAUNT: It's coming.
Like, I think they are literally
trying to get to
that last final step.
It's coming.
RICH HYNDMAN: Excellent.
NICK BUTCHER: Like Google
Play Store.
KRISTAN UCELLO: Thanks, guys.
All right.
RICH HYNDMAN: Google
Play Store.
It's coming.
KRISTAN UCELLO: I've got to
go catch my bus, so--
RICH HYNDMAN: All
right, Crispy.
Cheers.
KRISTAN UCELLO: I will
see you guys later.
Ciao.
RICH HYNDMAN: Get out of here.
NICK BUTCHER: No worries.
RICH HYNDMAN: Great.
[SIGHS].
MAXIM: Hey, guys?
MATT GAUNT: Hi.
RICH HYNDMAN: Hey.
MAXIM: It's just me again.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
MAXIM: So have you checked
the APQ, the APG 2.1?
Well, it returns the list of
permission that I would expect
it to return.
It returns all the permissions
defined in the manifest, and
the Market still shows
different lists.
And I'm sure it's a safe file.
NICK BUTCHER: Cool.
Can you host the APK somewhere,
like put it on
Drive and send us
a link to it?
And we can take a look.
MAXIM: Yeah, definitely.
Definitely.
So what should I use to--
oh.
There's a Chat I use.
Should use a Chat to
send it to you.
NICK BUTCHER: Can you put it
in a comment to the Hangout
announcement on G+, not in the
Chat comments, because they
all go away.
RICH HYNDMAN: If you don't
mind distributing
your APK to the world.
[LAUGHS].
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
Or you could just share
it with us personally.
Post it on G+.
RICH HYNDMAN: What was the
name of the application?
MAXIM: I would prefer so,
because it's, well--
NICK BUTCHER: Sure.
MAXIM: It's private.
So where could I send?
RICH HYNDMAN: What's the name
of the application?
MAXIM: Uber.
[LAUGHS].
RICH HYNDMAN: Can
you spell that?
MAXIM: U-B-E-R.
RICH HYNDMAN: Uber?
NICK BUTCHER: Oh,
like the taxi.
MAXIM: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: Oh, cool.
RICH HYNDMAN: Nice.
MAXIM: Actually, it's
on the Market now.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes.
It was in the Market
before now.
So you've uploaded--
NICK BUTCHER: But you've
updated it?
Despite the--
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
NICK BUTCHER: --permission
thing.
MAXIM: Yeah, I did.
NICK BUTCHER: OK.
Well, we can grab
it from there.
That's cool.
Was that clear?
MAXIM: Yeah, thanks.
NICK BUTCHER: All right.
MAXIM: So should I come back,
like, to the next "Office
Hours," or to the next
15 minutes, or--
[INAUDIBLE]?
NICK BUTCHER: Always
come back to the
"Office Hours." [LAUGHTER]
RICH HYNDMAN: Yes!
Our next "Office Hours"
will be from Devoxx.
So it's going to be a slightly
different format.
There'll be a lot of Googlers
speaking at Devoxx [LAUGHS]
next week, the very nice
developer conference.
So it may be taking a slightly
different format next week.
But it should be at about
the same time.
MAXIM: I see.
RICH HYNDMAN: We'll try and get
back to you on the Uber
thing slightly separately.
Outside of the "Office Hours."
MAXIM: All right.
RICH HYNDMAN: Questions?
MAXIM: Just in case, I'll type
my email in the Chat.
Thanks.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
The problem with the Chat is
we lose it as soon as the
"Office Hours" goes off air.
MAXIM: So, in the
Moderator, then.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, yeah.
Somewhere like that.
In the thread or the
Moderator is fine.
OK.
NICK BUTCHER: First chat
in the sidebar.
CHRIS BANES: "Are you
attending Droidcon
Netherlands?
ALL UK DEVELOPERS: Yes.
RICH HYNDMAN: Marijn, we will be
at Droidcon Netherlands on
the 23rd and 24th, maybe?
Maybe 24th and 25th.
NICK BUTCHER: See you there.
RICH HYNDMAN: See you there.
Excellent.
Do we have any more questions
coming through the Moderator?
Sparky?
SPARKY RHODE: Mm.
Let's take a quick look.
RICH HYNDMAN: Thanks, dude.
SPARKY RHODE: I'm only counting
eight, and there were
eight last time we
answered one.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah.
I agree.
NICK BUTCHER: Through
the thread.
SPARKY RHODE: Let's see.
Yeah.
Still only eight.
I think we've hit them all.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: Is it possible
to use the YouTube API?
You already talked about the--
SPARKY RHODE: [LAUGHS].
NICK BUTCHER: So it's
coming soon.
Yeah.
They were taking beta testing,
but I'm not convinced that's
going on anymore, because, like
I said, they are kind of
getting to their final stages.
So at the moment I'm not aware
of any more developers getting
on board at the moment.
YOSSI ELKRIEF: OK.
NICK BUTCHER: Yet.
RICH HYNDMAN: All right.
Well, if there's no other
questions today, you want me
to wrap it up a little
bit early?
YOSSI ELKRIEF: No.
GIUSEPPE: Sorry, but there must
be one of my questions.
[LAUGHTER]
GIUSEPPE: Yay.
[ECHO]
RICH HYNDMAN: Go on, go ahead.
GIUSEPPE: Can I go?
Please.
Yes.
I would like to know if there
is any guideline for what is
permitted and what not?
Let's suppose, for example, that
we would like to import
the view from another
application, OK?
That has been done with another
application, into the
own application and extract the
algo from vis-a-vis view.
What is permitted
from the policy?
And if there is any policy
about what or not is
permitted, where
can I find it?
RICH HYNDMAN: So that would
very much depend on the
guidelines for that
application.
[ECHO].
So it's a bit of a
strange use case.
But if they're going to allow
the Share intent--
send intent to share their video
to other applications--
then they're expecting to send
the video to social networks--
G+, Facebook, et cetera.
And then it shares to your
application, and your
application then pulls the
soundtrack off it.
The use of that soundtrack will
be under the guidelines
of the application that
shared it in the
first place, I guess.
Certainly--
MATT GAUNT: There is stuff
in the content
policy, isn't there?
About not interfering with
another app's data?
RICH HYNDMAN: There is.
It's true.
NICK BUTCHER: Don't see
anyone I know of.
RICH HYNDMAN: App functionality
of data.
NICK BUTCHER: You've
got to be--
RICH HYNDMAN: It does sound--
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah, I think
which is the right here is to
make it easy for people to send
their content to your
app, rather than going out and
scanning for other content.
Sounds like the right way to--
GIUSEPPE: Yeah, but the problem
is that the data will
not be like it was sent.
It would be managed, it
would be changed.
It would be extract something
from inside.
So this is the question.
The video application share
with me the video.
That is it.
But I'm extracting something
from inside.
I'm doing something wrong?
Or can I do this?
Or I can do this?
SPARKY RHODE: This begins
to sound like more
like a legal question.
GIUSEPPE: Yes.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, I agree.
[ECHO].
I actually know in some respects
what it's related to.
GIUSEPPE: The problem is that
the content that was shared
with my app, it's not owned by
the other app, but it's owned
by the user.
So if there is some legal
action will be
against me and the user.
But if the user want a legal
action against me, why he
share the subject with me?
I don't know if it's clear,
the question.
But probably we need a lawyer.
SPARKY RHODE: Hm.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, it may be
something that YouTube's
referring to.
[ECHO]
GIUSEPPE: YouTube content is a
little bit different, because
we know that YouTube
don't want that we
manage the files, probably.
This isn't their policy.
But I'm talking about a
standalone file that is on the
device, and not imported
from outside or
downloaded from YouTube.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, so there's
certain [INAUDIBLE]
good application playing
files from device.
Limited files.
These files, these apps will be
on video players and such
from Google Play Store.
It's just it's--
well, [LAUGHS]
what the users actually extract
from it afterwards can
be questionable.
[ECHO]
RICH HYNDMAN: As long as
you're not [INAUDIBLE].
Don't you think this
might be OK?
Sounds like a legal question.
[ECHO AND BACKGROUND NOISE]
MATT GAUNT: None of
us are lawyers.
Thought we were.
[LAUGHS].
NICK BUTCHER: High
anal lawyers.
CHRIS BANES: [LAUGHS].
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, you
might be able to
get around it with--
CHRIS BANES: [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHS].
RICH HYNDMAN: Dialogs,
things like that.
Just warning the user
not to use it for
any appdevs as well.
Make sure you only load up your
own content or you're
only-- you're not breaking any
copyright terms and conditions
by using this product to XYZ.
[ECHO]
GIUSEPPE: Something like, "Are
you sure you want to--
want that we extracted the
algo from your video?"
Something like that?
RICH HYNDMAN: No, it just-- why
don't you just walk down
the guidelines and only extract
audios from videos
that you own the rights to.
NICK BUTCHER: So what?
Just showing you--
[ECHO]
CHRIS BANES: Yeah.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yeah, maybe.
[ECHO]
RICH HYNDMAN: All right.
GIUSEPPE: OK, thank you.
RICH HYNDMAN: Cheers,
Giuseppe.
So I think we had some other
people bouncing in and out
during that.
Does anyone else have
a question?
What did Sparky just do?
CHRIS BANES: That's all.
RICH HYNDMAN: OK.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
If there's no other questions,
then we will wrap it up.
NICK BUTCHER: [LAUGHS].
What's going on, Yossi?
SPARKY RHODE: Thanks for
coming, everyone.
RICH HYNDMAN: Yossi's
being crazy.
Android says "Bye!" [LAUGHS].
Thanks for coming, everyone.
And as I say, next week
we'll be at Droidcon.
We hope very much to run--
NICK BUTCHER: Pickles.
RICH HYNDMAN: Excuse me?
NICK BUTCHER: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER].
RICH HYNDMAN: Because we've
enjoyed your screen.
Next week we'll be at Devoxx.
Very much want to--
NICK BUTCHER: Watch out for a
special edition of various
"Office Hours."
RICH HYNDMAN: They are at the
normal time, normal place.
But you do double check
on developers.googl
e.com/live/android just in case
we have to shift the time
to match some of the
Devoxx scheduling.
Thank you all very much,
and see you next week.
[ECHO]
GIUSEPPE: Someone can share
the link of Droidcon?
[LAUGHTER]
NICK BUTCHER: Droidcon.com
or something like that.
RICH HYNDMAN: [INAUDIBLE]
at Droidon.com.
GIUSEPPE: [LAUGHS].
I will Google, I will Google.
[LAUGHS].
RICH HYNDMAN: Cheers,
Giuseppe.
See you all.
Thanks very much.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks, guys.
MAXIM: Bye.